[Applause]
everything is
racist it's racist if you do races if
you don't they were going to B ban
menthols but now they won't so what's
the minty fresh scent in the air could
be old Joe's embalming fluid or a
freshly lit Newport the Biden
Administration proposed ban on menthal
sigs has once again been delayed until
next year it's nice to see Joe putting
off something besides death
so why the delay turns out race is once
again at play you see menthols are a
popular product in the black community
which is why many view a proposed ban as
unfairly targeting Black customers
therefore a ban is racist yet many
health organizations Claim by not
Banning menthols more black smokers will
suffer Health consequences and
potentially die so that's racist too
it's very confusing keeping more black
people from getting lung cancer is
racist but allowing a cancer-causing
agent to kill more blacks is also racist
so what's it going to be virtue
signaling liberals you made this bed now
fall asleep while smoking in
it so it's no wonder the White House is
kicking the can down the road refusing
to choose a side for fear of being
labeled racist by fellow Libs it's quite
the Dilemma what do liberals love more
identity politics or interfering in
people's lives it's like women's sports
if they say boys should play in boy
sports that's transphobia but if they
say boys beat the crap out of girls in
women sports that obviously misogynistic
a smart person would realize at this
point identity politics is full
on but is menthol really the biggest
Health threat in the black community
what about crime lack of school choice
or joking about Jada pinket
Smith maybe Joe should let people smoke
whatever they want after all it's worked
out well with his
son tyus I go to you for Wow
Crazy by the way I got this idea because
freaking Jesse asks that's the first
thing he asked you on his show last
night that's why I smack Jesse around
off camera yeah like oh Tyrus what do
you think of these men and I threw it
back at him and he was like I'm sorry
listen this is an aair this is a threat
okay this is a threat see word has it
that black voters are gravitating more
towards Trump and Republicans so there
is listen we were going to save you from
menthols but since you want to vote for
the right guess what more menthol
so now you'll never make it to voting
how about that cuz if you don't smoke
menthols and vote for Joe you ain't
black so to up this is the dumbest ever
this isn't 1976 nobody smokes anymore
it's not even a big thing like there's
just we're all just walking around with
menthols how many times have you and cat
had to walk through me walking up and
down thing with my menthols checking on
my girls in the street and see if
they're bringing me those dubs I've been
waiting on
like this is isn't a sweater this is a
pimp vest it's ridiculous I thought you
were going to ask me how many menthols
I've smoked and the answer is we from
Detroit quite a few yeah you're like R
more but I've had quite a few menthol
cigarettes because you off people oh I I
smoked menthols in college yeah we share
we share the cancer stick why not yeah I
did the dumbest stuff ever no I love the
Washington Post article that said one of
the reasons they decided to not go
through with this band was were worried
they would affect his election prospects
and I just love the idea that out there
there are single-issue
voters their single issues meth all six
but you know but but the whole idea of
banning something would anger me but
also what CAD said is they're willing to
say oh it's going to kill them but we
need their vote so we'll like they put
the vote ahead of that person he's
literally going to say black people I'm
giving you menthols
yes
Joe did you ever smoke I never like
cigarettes never like cigarett and yet
you're still short it's it's it's like
it's like you could have smokes I
started off stunted yes emotionally too
uh it's such a such a classic example of
creating a problem where there wasn't
one and then figuring out oh how do we
get ourselves out look if it had been a
ban on something that white people like
there would have been a federal law
against mayonnaise passed immediately
and they would have been dealing with
this but it's it reminds me of when uh
school has a menu for Black History
Month and then a couple of loud mouths
say well we don't like that and they
take the menu away and everyone else is
like what happened to the ribs and the
cornbread everybody loves that stuff
it's delicious so they they're creating
problems that they don't know how to
solve I think like hey Smoke them if you
got them I'm not a cigarette smoker if
if that's your way you want to kill
yourself I don't care go right ahead but
it is funny the idea of like if you
could just hang in there and not die of
lung cancer until after November yeah
and then we'll B it message then we
Menthol in every well you don't own
homes so uh in every pot in every well
Menthol in every
pot Menthol next to your pot yes K KT uh
why are menthols so different from other
cigarettes I have no idea you were in
the
military I worked at the Pentagon for a
number of years but you know the
campaign commercial that I can't wait to
see guess who used to smoke Cool
cigarettes who Barack Obama oh that's
right yeah are those menthols I can't
remember cool come on oh I I don't know
cool not be just because it was cool but
they they were mental cool is the best
name for any product yeah by the way I'm
going to have to say this I don't care
just doing a segment on cigarettes makes
me want to smoke isn't it it's the most
powerful powerful product on the planet
I just want to light up and have a cig I
bet people right now feel the same way
don't do it Uncle Greg says
no
H Uncle Greg coming up some silly woke
toys in Christmas tree PLO hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else